los resultados de las elecciones de
constituyentes mostraron un respaldo a
candidatos independientes y una derrota
indudable para los partidos
tradicionales cómo queda configurado
entonces el reparto de las fuerzas para
la redacción de la nueva constitución
muy buenos días ángel a la verdad que
las elecciones de este fin de semana en
chile ratificaron un movimiento social y
político que surgió el año 2019 en
octubre y que posteriormente se expresó
mayoritariamente en el plebiscito del
año recién pasado y en estas elecciones
fue ratificado ese mismo espíritu de
cambios de buscar nuevas alternativas de
más bien nuevas alternativas yo diría
que son cambios al proceso y a la
sociedad en su conjunto y a la propia
conducción del estado yo creo que eso es
lo que refrescó mayoritariamente este
este proceso electoral y como tú bien
dices lo segundo es que golpeó muy
fuerte a los partidos tradicionales que
habían estado vigentes durante estos 30
años desde el retorno a la democracia el
chip
los comicios también marcaron un duro
golpe para el presidente sebastián
piñera quien ya arrastraba una imagen
muy deteriorada después de muchas
derrotas que se vislumbra para el tramo
final de su mandato
naturalmente un gobierno con el 9 por
ciento de aprobación ciudadana eso
golpea muy fuerte no solamente al
gobierno sino que golpeó fuertemente a
su coalición política al conglomerado
chile ban quien obtuvo sólo el 2020
infracción por ciento de todos los votos
eso esto es una derrota histórica que
ese conglomerado no había tenido desde
la vuelta a la transición por lo tanto
yo creo que ahora van a venir una serie
de disputas internas de disputas del
liderazgo y de posiciones políticas al
interior del conglomerado oficialista y
naturalmente el gobierno ya está en una
etapa muy final de su propio mandato y
yo tiendo a pensar que el escenario
político se va a ir centrando en el
debate constitucional fundamentalmente y
en los cambios necesarios que el país
ha determinado que se deben hacer
bueno ya para terminar conocida la
configuración de la asamblea
constituyente cuáles son los próximos
pasos para la redacción de la nueva
constitución lograrán plasmar los
principales reclamos de la protesta
social que ésta dio en 2019
yo creo que si tienen un plazo a contar
de un mes más se tienen que instalar y
de ahí tienen nueve meses o máximo un
año para redactar la nueva constitución
yo creo que la configuración de
mayoritariamente grupos independientes
el triunfo de la izquierda en desmedro
de la centroizquierda y la derrota de la
derecha creo que van a marcar el
desarrollo de esta asamblea
constituyente naturalmente el mayor
desafío que tienen los constituyentes es
darle viabilidad y haber entendido bien
el resultado de esta elección que el
país necesita y requiere cambios para un
nuevo pacto social